phil mickelson sending out a statement
yesterday
that he's stepping away from the game
for a while
and uh what ended up um preceding all of
this was a quote in a book that is uh
um coming out um and an excerpt from the
book that was put on the fire pit
collective which is the current riding
home for this man who's been
writing about golf for quite some time
um he is the writer on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line alan ship not kind a lot
kind enough to call in the rich eisen
show amidst uh i'm sure your phone's
blowing up these days
sir
it's been an eventful few days but i
always have time for you rich i
appreciate that i appreciate that alan
so um let's get right into this here
this is your your from your uh
unauthorized right biography of phil
mickelson the rip roaring and
unauthorized biography of golf's most
colorful superstar phil
um
what what's the uh the uh context of the
quote and everything that's uh going on
if you want to
start with that
yeah well i'm not sure how much your
your listeners have been tuned into the
saudi golf league but this has been
bubbling up for the better part of a
year and
phil has been in the middle of all of it
you know as he told me he actually
helped pay for the attorney that would
write the operating agreement of the sgl
which was which was a bold move
considering you know the pg tour has
always been his home and
has been a great platform for him to uh
build a fortune and reach the hall of
fame but
you know phil loves to stir the pot and
he likes to be the smartest guy in the
room so
you know he recognized that the saudi
golf league was kind of a once in a
lifetime chance to have some leverage
over the tour and and try and
force the tour to make some changes that
would
benefit all the players but especially
him and so
he uh he was working both sides of the
street
and
what what phil wanted what was in his
heart was really one of the big
questions in golf
he told me all of that
and
it was all going in the book as the
saudi golf league was coming to a boil
it felt like
you know my book's not coming out till
may and this was just too important to
the discourse of what's really going on
in the world of golf right now so we
dropped the excerpt
a couple weeks ago last week and
things have gone a little crazy since
then but
you know i to some degree i'm surprised
by the
um the blowback on phil because it was
pretty obvious all along what he was
doing which was which was trying to play
the the saudis against the tour and
and and see what kind of deal he could
cut for himself i mean everybody who was
paying attention knew that but he you
know he said the quiet parts out loud
and
that was so eye-catching and
you know raw unvarnished truth is uh
it's a precious commodity in in sports
these days and phil just put it out
there so
um
the blowback has been so much that
you've taken a little time away to
let things cool down and
reassess and plot his next move but
uh it's definitely been an interesting
chapter in in his career and certainly
it's an interesting chapter in the book
all right so then let's let's get into
um
a little bit about what phil said and
then some and then fill in maybe
backfill about what this no pun intended
about what what what this beef with the
pga tour is all about
alan shipnuck the the writer of the uh
book phil uh from which this quote that
uh that uh
has led to the firestorm uh right here
on the rich eisen show the quote in in
in question it appears from phil's
statement yesterday was
he said off the record
um i'll give you the floor on that alan
well patently false and disappointing
because
i mean phil phil knew all this was for
the book he was
first of all he
you have to understand phil's motivation
is he he wanted to go on record with his
true feelings because then he was
covered either way
by by calling the the saudis scary mofos
and and
acknowledging some of the their
atrocities that's his signal to golf
fans if you know if he wound up going
over there and taking the money at least
he would he would have registered
the
some sort of a conscience and some sort
of a understanding of global affairs and
that this is just strictly a business
decision and you want people to know
that
if he stayed with the pga tour it might
have looked like a defeat but he wanted
he wanted fans to know that he'd
extracted all these concessions
and that he was he was really working
hard behind the scenes to get what he
wanted because phil just has this need
to
be the loudest voice in the room and
certainly the smartest one that's just
part of his personality it makes him fun
to be around but it also gets him in
trouble but
you know he initiated this conversation
with me
it is an unauthorized biography and he i
think three times i approached him face
to face to sit for interviews for the
book and he declined which was his
prerogative and that was fine because
i'd had so much access to phil through
the years i didn't really need him but
um as this saudi stuff was heating up
and he realized it was going to really
impact his legacy in the sport he wanted
to make his feelings known to me he
asked if we could speak
uh i said yes of course even though he
said he only wanted to talk about about
these issues and i was there's something
i would have rather have gotten into but
you know he was he was kind of setting
the ground rule so i said fine
and you know not once did he ask to go
off the record
and i certainly never consented to that
and it's a two-way street you know when
um
when you're doing an interview
if he had asked i certainly would have
pushed back because this is my one
chance to talk to him for the book
but he just he just started talking and
you know i think phil
in his mind this wasn't going to come
out until may when the book is released
and
um you know at that point everything
would have been done and dusted you
would have signed on the dotted line to
the saudis or not
uh but because
events are moving so quickly and i've
been hearing from people close to the
saudi golfing there's gonna be
announcement the week of the players
championship it's only a couple you know
a couple weeks from now
it just seemed like we had to get this
this stuff out into the world so golf
fans could really understand phil's
motivation and and what was going on
here
so
that's the whole back story but
the record the the the quotes were
certainly on the record phil knew that i
knew that and for him to say otherwise
it's disappointing
so um
i'm drinking all that in right now
so um
basically
uh because it made no sense him saying
that it was off the record but he's
apologizing for it and stepping away
for it right because that means what off
the record meant
that he didn't want it out there
and right but it's still
something that he's now apologizing for
and stepping away for like what is the
stepping away for do you think
what do you think that that means
why do you think he's stepping away
it could be a codeword for being
suspended by the pga tour for you know
conduct unbecoming
um
i'm not sure the tour would want to go
down that road because in some ways it
would prove their
phil's point that they're they're you
know
reactionary bad guys but uh you know
this
phil's been playing fast and loose for a
long time i mean whether you're talking
about
um the billy walters insider trading
escapade
the 2018 us open where he would hit a
moving ball on the green string caught
killed and ignited a firestorm and then
tried to bs his way out of it
you know throwing tom watson under the
bus of 2014 ryder cup i mean
phil loves to stir the pot and
i do think it's taking a toll and
there's a lot of stuff in his life that
the public doesn't know about and it's
all in the book and
there's a lot of stress in his life all
of his own doing of course and so
i think maybe
he's just his nervous system is maxed
out right now and and he does need to
reset and do some reflection and
some self-improvement so
um
i i take that at face value but there
could be a pga
you know one of those situations where
i'm gonna jump before you push me as far
as any kind of suspension
um
you know the tour never speaks publicly
about any disciplinary action so we'll
never know for sure but
uh it's kind of analogous to dustin
johnson back in
2006 when he took that that six-month
you know quote-unquote leave of absence
to address you know personal challenges
he called them and
you know was he suspended or did he take
leave of absence it was basically the
same thing but
you know dustin came back from that a
much better player and person and i wish
the same thing for phil mickelson i mean
in in the wake of all this i've had
people say oh is this book are you
trying to take down phil is this a hit
job
it's not like that i mean the book is
written with a certain amount of
affection i've always enjoyed covering
phil
and there's a lot of laugh out out loud
moments in the book there's a lot of
outrageous stories yeah everyone has
everyone has and that's why part of this
is he's kind of like you know oh damn it
so he's not going to follow up what he
did at the pga championship with the
masters like
right i mean
we were just remarking back to the
masters i i don't think this is gonna
this is not gonna stretch on for months
and months do you think he'll be back
for the masters then huh i think we'll
be back to the masters that's his
favorite place
you know it's it's a it's an artificial
reality he can he can call a shot on
whether he wants to do a press
conference or not and control the whole
scene just like tiger did when he came
back from the sex scandal so i would be
amazed if phil's not back at the masters
and honestly i think hillary merchant
was more popular than ever
we know sports fans love a redemption
story and they love a comeback and a
slightly more humble less cartoonish
phil mickelson i think people will
embrace and
you know he's kind of turned into a
cartoon character in recent
years with you know all the preening
about his calf muscles and hitting these
bombs off the tee and the hair dye that
that you know he's like ruiji the
audience can start leaking down his
forehead one of these days and all this
stuff and
i think that you know there's a lot to
like about phil he's an incredible
philanthropist he's
he does many random acts of kindness uh
and
he's a smart guy he's probably not quite
as smart as he thinks but he's a smart
thoughtful person and
so i i think that
you know this time of reflection will
serve him well and
you know
people are saying oh this is going to
destroy his legacy i mean that's a very
short memory phil's been engulfed in
controversies off and on his entire
career and he remains wildly popular i
mean it's almost part of his brand and
even though he set himself on fire with
the saudi golf league
i mean the fact is it kind of it's on
brand you know he he's a self-styled
maverick he was trying to reshape some
of the terms professional golf and you
know was he driven by money you know
obviously but
i do think part of him thought it was
for the greater good and
um
you know he if you if you if you pay
attention to granular details a lot of
what he wanted he's already accomplished
i mean
because of the saudi threat the pga tour
is pumping 100 million dollars this year
back to the players more than did last
year with increased purses and bonuses
and
player impact program and all these
things and
you know phil has to get credit for some
of that and they've created this nft
platform which probably would have
happened eventually but it happened
really fast because phil was pushing
hard for that so
and there's some other things that that
still you know may come of all his
behind-the-scenes advocacy so
even the players who have had some
unkind things to say about them if
they're paying attention
um they're not that mad at still i mean
he's making them even richer than they
already were so
um you know phil's gonna survive this
he's a survivor he's been through so
many
kerfuffles this is just the latest one
and
you know the the whiff of
the saudi tate is a little different i
mean
i don't think he
quite understood it's still an emotional
topic for a lot of people given that
they supplied 16 of the 19 911 hijackers
and
obviously the recent you know killing of
jamal khashoggi i mean
for phil i think he thought he was just
being a shrewd businessman and he didn't
quite get that this is this is different
if it would if if this golf league was
was supplied by you know european
interests
people would not have had the same
reaction but saudi arabia is still very
toxic and emotional for a lot of folks
and i don't think phil understood that
alan shipnook i appreciate the time here
um uh so the book comes out in may and
you put the excerpt out
now because it was newsworthy can you
can you tell people in the washington
beltway how it's done can you do that
because well you know i mean do you have
friends in the washington beltway who
who sit on write books and sit on stuff
for a year and then it comes out and it
would have been nice to know when it was
actually timely and newsworthy just like
you just did yeah and that was part of
my motivation is i didn't want to go
down that road i mean
because the saudi thing was was really
about to happen and
it may still happen but i just felt like
it's time for for everyone to put their
cards on the table and
you know simon schuster was not super
stoked i mean as you as you know uh they
generally publishers want
you know the excerpts and the juicy
stuff come out right around publication
but right i just felt you know
ultimately my job is as a troop teller
and i'm not on the side of the pj tour
or for phil mickelson or the saudi golf
league
i don't have a dog in the fight other
than i just want people to be informed
and they can make their own decisions
and this was just too relevant to sit on
it but
you can pre-order the book now yes very
good
exactly please do that no obviously i'm
sure there's other stuff uh in there of
interest and and as you point out phil
is one of the most fascinating sports
figures that america's put on an
international stage um of of our time of
his time and um
and it's definitely uh worthy for
everyone to go get so you think the
saudi league is still alive like this is
possible even though
you've seen the reaction of people like
rory mcilroy and others on the
international stage like him um
and that
phil's phil's not going to be part of it
clearly um
what do you think he could have you
haven't filmed that quite renounced the
uh right saudis and if you read
his statement which is a bit of a word
salad
um
you know he had a lot he it was like he
was trying to mend fences with them so i
i wouldn't say filled out completely yet
i mean all the saudis have to do is add
an extra zero to everybody's offer and
this thing could come back from the dead
and they have the ability to do that so
um
we'll see i mean it's been mortally
wounded as a concept but it's not dead
and
and
i'm sorry is it true that that trump is
the one who would be housing uh or
holding these tournaments is that the
what you're hearing like where would the
tournaments be
it's proposed to be a 13 tournaments
uh schedule nine would be in the u.s and
three trump courses were in the mix so
yeah i mean it's a perfect marriage
right um
you wouldn't be hosting all of them but
that would be a significant number
and you know jared kushner was over at
the saudi international golf tournament
a few weeks ago that phil played in
modular guys and there's a lot of behind
the scenes deal-making so yeah there's
no doubt that the trump courses are in
the mix
but
i think phil's best move is to
his next statement but you know i
thought about it and even though the
money was tempting my heart's
with the pj tour which has been such a
wonderful platform for me and i'll
quietly work to make it better but
you know i think if and when he
renounces the saudi golf league that
would be helpful to him
but they're not easily deterred i mean
we'll see what happens i i think
losing dustin johnson and bryson to
shambo who ran to the hills as soon as
phil's um quotes came out and that hurt
because they were two of the biggest
names had been attached to it but i'm
not sure the saudis really care about
world ranking points they just want to
have tournaments and they'll get the
best players they can get and
the insidious thing about sports
washington is that it works because by
if they launch this thing by
year two there'll be less resistance and
you know more players may sign up and
you know i think they're just they're
playing a long game so i
it i don't know who's excited with howdy
golf league but i'm not ready to
pronounce it dead just yet
alan thanks for the time um look forward
to seeing the entire book um and
come back in may when when uh when
you're promoting it and we'll have you
on and uh make sure everything's
copacetic with your your publisher
because you know i'm
no i'm serious man i mean what you did
um i'm sure there were some people in in
simon and schuster saying what do you
mean we're going to do this now well i
appreciate that and i will say there's
there's so much else in this book that
people are going to enjoy and there's
more revelations coming i mean we're
going to talk about this for a while so
i'll take up on that offer but thank you
let's do it thanks for the call now
appreciate it
alan shipnock right here from the
firepit collective
and also his book um if we can put it up
on the screen one more time called phil
and i think the photograph is from him
from the his most recent major win
standing there or just him with his
son's shades that was that was the shot
at the pga last year oh man the rip
roaring and unauthorized biography of
golf's most colorful superstar and then
that's why i'm sure people are going to
be very confused it's unauthorized so
why did phil speak to him for an
unauthorized biography that he said
three different times i don't want to
talk to you and then he's like i'll talk
to you specifically about this right
according to alan and then alan's
sure he could have knocked him over with
a feather when he saw in the statement
yesterday that his comments were taken
off the
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here